What if we lost our entire
atmosphere all at once?
Let's say the years magnetic field took
a break and allowed strong solar winds
to come and strip away our
protective space, blanket
with earth instantly turn
into a big lifeless rock.
Would you still be able to breathe?
Could our atmosphere ever come back?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if our
atmosphere vanished into thin air.
Just how important is the atmosphere
to our planet? It's absolutely vital.
It protects us from asteroids and solar
radiation. It regulates our climate.
It makes life on earth possible.
Our nearest neighbor,
Mars lost most of its atmosphere
some 4 billion years ago,
and look what's become of it once warm
and wet in eight the planet it used to be,
it's atmosphere has advantaged completely.
There's still a very thin layer left,
but have you ever heard
of any life found on Mars?
What exactly what happened to Earth
when the atmosphere went away? Well,
it's far from a happy ending.
Take away the earth's atmosphere and
suddenly it would become very, very quiet.
You wouldn't hear a thing.
That's because sound waves are actually
vibrations in the air, but no air,
no sound.
There's no sound in space.
The Star Wars universe
just isn't accurate.
The Sky would turn black because there
would be no particles in the air to
scatter the blue light of sunshine. Planes
would plummet to the ground and birds,
they need air pressure to
support them as they fly. Oceans,
lakes and rivers would start acting weird
as well with no atmospheric pressure.
The boiling point of water would
drop significantly from 100 degrees.
All of our swatter would start
boiling away like a forgotten kettle.
Not all of it would turn to vapor.
Soon we'd reach an equilibrium with
enough vapor to prevent the water from
boiling, but with zero
atmospheric pressure, the
water wouldn't remain liquid.
What's left of it would turn into ice,
grab a winter coat as it's going to get
pretty chilly without an atmosphere to
trap heat near the surface,
Earth's temperature would drop to
an average of minus 18 degrees and
temperatures would see extreme
shifts between day and night.
Now slather on the sunscreen because
even with temperatures that low,
you can still get sunburned without
the atmosphere to filter solar.
Radiation sunbathing would become lethal,
but would you even survive that long?
Only if you had a pressure suit and an
oxygen mask on. Without those two things,
you're no longer with us.
In order to inhale,
your diaphragm uses the
pressure difference between
the air inside your lungs
and the air outside of your body.
Without outside pressure,
you wouldn't be able to breathe even
if you are hooked up to our respirator,
but don't hold your breath. Your lungs
would pop in a matter of seconds.
Exhaling would help your body stay
alive for about three minutes,
but you'd be unconscious
after just 15 seconds.
Everything that needs oxygen would
die. All animals, all plants.
That includes everything
in the oceans too,
but there's still be some bacteria left.
Maybe it would evolve into
something intelligent.
Eventually solar radiation would break
the water vapor down into oxygen.
Combine that with the carbon dioxide
pumped for volcanoes and from geothermal
vents,
and it would create a new atmosphere,
but this would be long after humans
are gone and too thin for us to breathe
anyway.
Now take a deep breath because
can
and relax.
No massive media or coronal objection
is likely to strip away our atmosphere
anytime soon. And from now on, try
to appreciate every sunset you see.
If we ended up fleeing this
planet to colonize Mars,
they won't look this beautiful.
Okay.